The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today
we are introducing
an exciting new pledge in 6034.
Anyone who has already looked at
any of the neural net problems
will have easily been able to
see that even though Patrick
only has them back
up to 2006 now,
there's still-- well out of
four tests, perhaps two or three
different ways that the
neural nets were drawn.
Our exciting new pledge is
we're going to draw them
in a particular way this year.
And I will show you which
way, assuming that this works.
Yes.
We are going to draw them
like the one on the right.
The one on the left is the
same as the one on the right.
At first, not having
had to explain
the difference between
the two of them,
you might think you want
the one on the left.
But you really want
the one on the right,
and I'll explain why.
The 2007 quiz was drawn,
roughly similarly, to this.
Although if you somehow wind up
in tutorial or somewhere else
doing one of the older
quizzes, a lot of them
were drawn exactly like this.
In this representation, one
thing I really don't like,
is that the inputs are
called x's, and the outputs
are called y's, but there's
two x's, so the inputs are not
x and y, and then they often
correspond to x's of a graph,
and then people get confused.
Additional issues
that many people have
are the fact that the summation
and the multiplication
with the weight is implied.
The weights are written on the
edges, where outputs and inputs
go, and the summation of
the two inputs into the node
are also implied.
But take a look here.
This is the same net.
These w's here would be
the w's that are written
onto these lines are here.
Actually the better
way to draw it
would be like so,
since each of these
can have their own w,
which is different.
So each of the w's
that are down here,
are being explicitly
set to a multiplier.
Where as here, you
just had to remember
to multiply the weight by
the input that was coming by.
Here you see an input,
comes to a multiplier,
you multiply by the weight,
then once you multiplied
all the inputs by the weight,
then you send them to a sum,
so the sigma is just a
sum, you sum them, add them
all together, send the result of
that into the sigmoid function,
our old buddy, 1 over 1 plus
e to the negative whatever
our input was, with a
weight for an offset,
and then we send
the result of that
into more multipliers with
more weights, more sums, more
sigmoids.
So this is how it's going
to look like on the quiz.
And this is a conversion
guide from version 0.9 data
into version 1.0.
So if you see
something that looks
like this, on one of the old
quizzes that you're doing,
see if you can convert it,
and then solve the problem.
Chances are if you
can convert it,
you're probably
going to do fine.
We'll start off not only
with this conversion guide,
but also-- I'll leave
that up here-- also
I'm going to work out the
formulas for you guys one more
time.
These are all the
formulae that you're
going to need on the quiz.
And then we're
going to decide what
will change in the formulae,
if, and this is a very
likely if, there seems to
be good amount of times
that this happens, is that
the sigmoid function in those
neurons out there
was ever changed
into some other
kind of function.
Hint.
It's changed into a plus
already in the problem
we're about to do.
People change it all the time
into some bizarro function.
I've seen arc tangent, I think.
So here we go.
Let's look at the front of it.
First of all, sigmoid.
Well our old buddy, sigmoid,
I just said it a moment ago,
sigmoid is 1 over 1
plus e to the minus x.
Also, fun fact about sigmoid,
the derivative of sigmoid,
is itself-- the
derivative of sigmoid
is-- let's say that the
sigmoid-- we'll just
turn sigmoid into
like the letter say y.
Y is the result, right?
So if you say y equals 1 over
1 plus e to the negative x,
then the derivative of
sigmoid is y times 1 minus y.
You can also write out
the whole nasty thing,
it's 1 over 1 plus e to the
negative x times 1 minus 1
over 1 plus e to negative x.
So the nice property
of sigmoid it's
going to be important for
us in the very near future,
and that future begins now.
So now the performance function.
This is a function we used
to tell neural nets when
they inevitably act up and
give us really crappy results.
At first we tell them
just how long they are,
with our performance function.
The first function can
be any sane function
that gives you a better score,
where better can be decided
as lower or higher, if you feel
like, that gives you a better
score, if your answers are
closer to the answer you're
looking for.
However, in this case, we
have, for a very sneaky reason,
chosen the performance
function to be
1/2 d, which is the
desired output, minus o,
the actual output squared.
So we want a small,
well it's negative,
So we want a small
negative or 0.
That would mean
we performed well.
So why this?
Well the main reason
is ddx of performance
is, the 2 comes down, the o
is the variable that we're
actually, so maybe I should say
ddo, that negative comes out,
we get a simple d minus o.
And yeah, we're using
derivatives here.
So those are fine.
These are two assumptions.
They could be
changed on your test.
We're going to figure out what
happens, if we change them,
if we change the performance,
if we change the sigmoid, that
is if we change the sigmoid
to some other function, what's
going to happen to the
next three functions, which
are basically the only
things that you need
to know to do backpropagation.
So let's look at that.
First, w prime.
This is the formula
for a new weight.
After one step of
backpropagation.
A new weight in any
of these positions
that you can see up here on
this beautiful neural net.
That w-- each of the w's will
have to change step by step.
That's, in fact, how you do
the hill climbing neural nets.
You change the
weights incrementally.
You step a little
bit in the direction
towards giving you your desired
results until eventually, you
hope, you have an
intelligent neural net.
And maybe you have many
different training examples
that you run it on,
in a cycle, hoping
that you don't over fit to
your one sample, on a computer.
But on the test, we will
probably will not do that.
So let's take a look
at how you calculate
the weights for the next level.
And then you have the weights
for the current level.
So first things first.
New weight, weight
prime equals--
starts with the old weight.
That has to go there
because otherwise we're
just going to jump off
somewhere at random.
We want to make a little
step in some direction,
so we want to start where
we are, with the weight.
And then we're going
to add three things.
So if we're talking
about the weight
between some i and
some j-- there's
some examples of the
names of weights.
So this is w 1 i, that's
the weight between 1
and-- so this is w 1 a, it's
the weight between 1 and a.
This is w 2 b, which is the
weight between 2 and b .
Makes sense?
Well makes sense
so far, but what
if it's just called
w b, then it's
the weight between-- these
w's that only have one letter,
we'll get to later.
They're the bias.
They're the offset.
They are always attached
to a negative 1.
So you can pretty much treat
them as being a negative 1
here, that is then fed into
a multiplier with this w b,
if you like.
This is implied to be that.
All of the offsets are
implied to be that.
So w plus sum of alpha--
why is this Greek letter?
Where does it come from?
How do we calculate it?
Well alpha is just some value
told to you on the quiz.
You'll find it somewhere.
There's no way you're going
to have to calculate alpha.
You might be asked to
try to give us an alpha,
but probably not.
Alpha is supposed to give
the size of our little steps
that we take when we're
doing hill climbing.
Very large alpha,
take a huge step.
Very small alpha,
take tentative steps.
So alpha is there, basically,
to change this answer
and to make the new value either
very close to w, or far from w,
depending on our taste.
So plus alpha times
i, so i is the value
coming in into the node.
We're changing the weight here.
So i is the value, for
instance, i sub 1 here,
i would be the value of WAC,
i would be the value coming
output of node a.
WBC, i would be the
output of node b.
i is sometimes as little
as i is the input coming in
to meet that weight
at the multiplier.
And then it's
multiplied by delta j.
Your delta is the
delta that belongs
to these neural net nodes.
What is a delta, you said?
Funny you may ask.
It is a strange Greek letter.
It sort of comes from
the fact that we're
doing some partial
derivatives and stuff,
but the main way you're going to
figure out what the deltas are
are these two formulae that
I've not written in yet.
So hold off on
trying to figure out
what the delta is until--
well right now, I'm
about to tell you the delta is.
So the delta is basically,
think of the delta
as using partial
derivatives to figure out
which way you're
going to step, when
you're doing hill climbing.
Because you know when
you're doing hill climbing,
you look around, you
figure out, OK, this
is the direction of
the highest increase,
and then you step off
in that direction.
So the deltas are
telling you which way
to step, with the weights.
And the way they do that is by
taking the partial derivative
of-- basically you
try to figure out
how the weight that you're
currently looking at
is contributing to the
performance of the net.
Contributing to, either
the good performance
of the net, or the bad
performance of the net.
So when you're dealing with
the weights, like WBC, WAC,
that pretty much directly
feed into the end of the net.
They feed into the last
node, and it then comes out.
It's the output.
That's pretty easy.
You can tell exactly
how much those weights,
and the values coming from them,
are contributing to the end.
And we do that by
essentially, remember
what the partial derivative,
so partial derivative here
is, in fact, the way that the
final weights are contributing
to the performance, is just
the performance function.
Partial derivative--
I've already
figured out the derivative
here, it's just d minus o.
This is for sort
of final weights,
the weights in the last level.
D minus o, except
we're not done yet,
because when we do derivatives,
remember the chain rule.
To get from the end to these
weights, we pass through,
well it should be a
sigmoid, here it's not,
we're going to pretend
it is for the moment,
we pass through a
sigmoid, and since we
passed through the
sigmoid, we had better
take the derivative of
the sigmoid function.
That is, y times 1 minus y.
Well what is y?
What is the output
of the sigmoid?
It's up.
So that's also multiplied
by o times 1 minus o.
However, there is
a-- let me see,
let me see, yes-- sorry, I'm
carefully studying this sheet
to make sure my
nomenclature is exactly
right for our new nomenclature,
which so new and brave,
that we're doing it, that
we only knew for sure we're
going to do it on Wednesday.
So we have d minus o
times o times 1 minus o.
So you say, that's fine,
that can get us these weights
here, even this w
c, how are we going
to get the deltas for
the new weights here?
Oh, I realize-- yeah, I got it.
So the delta-- by the
way, this is a delta c,
how is neuron c
contributing to the output?
Well it's directly
contributing to the output ,
and it's got a sigmoid in it.
It doesn't really, but we're
pretending it does for now.
d minus o times 1 minus o.
What about inner node?
Node d, node a, what are
we going to have to do?
Well the way they
contribute to the output is
that they contribute to node c.
So we can do this
problem recursively.
So let's do this recursively.
First of all, as you have
probably figured out,
all of them are going to have
an o times 1 minus o factoring
from the chain rule, because
they're all sigmoid, pretending
that they're all sigmoids.
We also have a dearth
of good problems
that are actually sigmoid
on the web right now.
There's only 2007.
But here's o times
1 minus o, what
are we going to do
for the rest of it?
How does it contribute
to our final result?
Well it contributes to our
final result recursively.
So we're talking about delta i.
I is an inner node.
It's not a final node.
It's somewhere along the way.
So sum over j of w, going
from i to j, times delta j.
Now sum over all j, j
such that i leads to j.
I needs to have a
direct path into j.
So if i, in this
instance, was j,
everyone, the only possible
j in this would be c.
That's right.
We would not sum over
b as one of the j.
i does not lead to b, or a does
not lead to b, a only leads
to c.
Also note that c does
not need to be here.
That's going backwards.
So you just-- to figure out
which j you're looking at,
look directly forwards
at the next one.
So if there was another d here,
or that a does not go to d,
a goes to c.
You only look at the
next level children,
and you sum over
all those children,
the weight between
them, multiplied
by the child's delta.
That makes sense, right?
Because the way we affect, if
the child's delta is the way
the child affects the output,
calling these children
for a moment, and then
if this one directly
affects the output,
then the way this one
affects it is-- it affects
it because it affects this,
but it's also multiplied
by it's weight.
So in fact, for instance, if the
weight between a and c were 0,
then a doesn't affect
the output at all, right?
Because its weight is 0,
and when we do this problem,
we go this times 0, and then
we try to add it in there,
doesn't affect anything.
It's weight is very high,
it's going to really
dominate c, and that is
taken into account here,
and then multiply by the
delta for the right node.
So the following
question, and since I
spent a lot of time with
formulae and not that much time
starting on the problem, I will
not call on someone at random,
but rather take a volunteer.
If no one volunteers,
I'll eventually
tell you, which is, we've
got some nice formulae
on the bottom three.
If we change the sigmoid
function, what has to change?
That's the only
thing that changes
in this crazy assed problem
right here, which by the way,
changes the sigmoid
functions into adders,
is that we take all
of the o times 1
minus o in delta
f and the delta i,
and we change it to
a new derivative.
We then do the exact same
thing that we would've done.
Correct.
And on a similar note, if
you change the performance
function, how many
of these equations
at all have to change
out of the bottom three.
Yeah.
That's right, just
one, just delta f.
Take the d minus o, make
it the new derivative
of the new performance function.
And in fact, delta i
doesn't change at all.
Does everyone see that?
Because it is very common
for something to be replaced,
I think three of the four
the quizzes that we have,
replaced in some-- changed
something in some way.
All right.
Let's go.
We're going to do
2008 quiz, because it
has a part of the end
that screwed up everyone,
and so let's make sure
we get to that part.
That's going to be the
part that you probably care
about the most at this point.
So these are all adders
instead of sigmoids.
That means that they simply
add up everything as normal,
for a normal neural
net, and then there's
no sigmoid threshold.
They just give
some kind of value.
Question?
STUDENT: So we talked about
those multiplier things,
we don't have those in nodes?
PROFESSOR: They're
not neural net nodes.
That is one of the reasons
why that other form that you
can see over there is elegant.
It only has the
actual nodes on it.
It is very compact.
It's one of the front we've
used in the previous tests.
The question is, do those
multipliers count as nodes?
However by not putting
in the multipliers,
we feel it sometimes confuses
people of explicitness.
The ones that are
nodes will always
have a label, like
a or here, you see
there's a sigmoid and an L1.
The multipliers are there
for your convenience,
to remind you to
multiply, and also
those, if you look those
sigmoids that are over there,
are there for your convenience
to remind you to add.
In fact, the only
thing that counts
as a node in the
neural net-- and that's
a very good question--
is usually the sigmoids,
here it's the adders.
We've essentially
taken out the sigmoids.
These adders are the-- oh,
here's the way to tell.
If it's got a threshold
weight associated with it,
then it's one of
the actual nodes.
A threshold weight.
I guess the multipliers look
like they have a weight,
but this is just the weight
that is being multiplied in.
This is our witness be
multiplied in with the input,
but if it has a threshold
weight, like wa,
wb-- oh, I promised
I would tell you guys
the difference between
the two weights.
So let's do that very quickly.
The kinds of weights that,
say w2b or w1a, our weight the
comes between input
1 and a or between a
and c, then mentally multiplying
the input by this weight,
and then eventually
that's added together.
The threshold weights, they
just have like wb, wa, wc.
They are essentially to decide
the threshold for a success
or failure, for a 1 or a
0, or anything in between,
at any of the given nodes.
So the idea is maybe
you at some node
want to have a
really high cut off,
you have to very high value
coming in, or else it's a 0.
So you put a high threshold.
The weight is multiplied
by negative 1.
And in fact, the threshold
weight won't-- one could
consider if you wanted to that
the threshold weight times
negative 1. was also
added in it that sum,
instead of putting at the
same location as the node.
If that works better for you,
when you're converting it,
you can also think
of it that way.
Because the threshold
weight is essentially
multiplied by negative
1 and added in
at that same sum over there.
So that's another way to do it.
There's a lot of ways to
visualize these neural nets.
Just make sure you have a
way that makes sense to you,
and that you can tell
pretty much whatever
we write, as long as it
looks vaguely like that,
how to get it in your mind,
into the representation
that works for you.
Because once you have the
representation right for you,
you're more than halfway
to solving these guys.
They aren't that bad.
They just look nasty.
They don't bite.
OK.
These are just adders.
So if it's just an
adder, then that
means that, if we take all
the x inputs coming in--
let's do x and y for the
moment, so we can figure out
the derivative--
then what comes out
after we just add up the x, what
comes out, y equals x, right?
We're just adding it up.
Adding up all the input, we're
not doing anything to it.
Y equals x is what
this node does.
You people see that?
So the derivative is just one.
So that's pretty easy, because
the first problem says,
what is the new
formula, delta f.
So I'll just tell you.
You guys probably
figured it out.
o times 1 minus o.
Because we replaced
d minus o with 1.
OK?
Makes sense so far?
Please ask questions
along the way,
because I'm not going
to be asking you guys.
I'll do it myself.
Question?
STUDENT: Why to we
use d minus o of 1?
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
The reason is because
I did the wrong thing.
So see, it's good that you
guys are asking questions.
It actually should be replaced
with o times 1 minus o with 1.
The answer is delta
f equals d minus o.
So yes, perhaps I
did it to trick you.
No, I actually messed up.
But yes, please ask
questions along the way.
Again, I don't have
time to call on you guys
at random to figure out if
you guys are following along.
So I'll do it myself.
We're placing the o times
1 minus o with 1 because
of the fact that
the sigmoid is gone,
and we get just delta
f equals d minus o.
So great.
We now want to know what
the equation is for delta i,
at the node a.
So delta a.
Well let's take a look.
The o times 1 minus o is gone.
Now we just have the sum over
j, which you guys already
told me is, only c
of WAC times delta c.
We know that delta
c is d minus o.
The answer is delta a is
just WAC times d minus o.
That time, I got it right.
I see the answer here.
Though it's written in
a very different format
from the old quiz.
Any questions on that?
Well that's part a that
we finished out of c.
Let's go to part b.
Part b is doing one
step backpropagation.
There's almost always going
to be one of these in here.
So the first thing it
asks is to figure out
what the output o is
for this neural net
if all weights are initially 1
except that this guy right here
is negative 0.5.
All the other ones
start off as 1.
Let's do a step-- oh, let's
see what are the inputs.
The inputs are also all 1.
Desired output is also 1.
And in fact, the rate
constant alpha is also 1.
This is the only thing
that isn't 1, folks.
So let's see what happens.
1 times 1 is 1, then
this is a negative 1
times 1 is negative 1.
That's 0.
The exact same thing happens
here because it's symmetrical.
So these are both 0.
0 times 1 is 0, 0 times 1 is 0.
Then this is negative 1 times
negative 0.5 is positive 0.5,
so 0 plus 0 plus a positive
0.5, the output is positive 0.5.
Does everyone see that?
If not, you can
convince yourself
that it is positive 0.5.
That would be a good
exercise for you,
run through one forward run.
The output is
definitely positive 0.5.
First time around.
OK?
Now we have to do one
step of backpropagation.
To do that, let's
calculate all the delta
so that we can calculate
all the new weights,
the the new weight primes.
So delta c.
That's easy.
You guys can tell
me what delta c is.
We figured out what the
new delta c is going to be.
So simple addition or
subtraction problem?
Everyone, delta c is?
STUDENT: 0.5.
PROFESSOR: 0.5, one half, yes.
All right.
We know that delta a and delta
b are just WAC times delta c,
and WBC times delta c.
So they are?
STUDENT: One half.
PROFESSOR: Also one half,
because all the weights were 1.
Easy street.
OK.
We've got all of the
deltas are one half.
And all but a few of
the weights are 1.
So let's figure out what
the new weights are.
New WAC, OK.
Yeah, so let's see.
What's going to be the new WAC?
So the new WAC is
going to be old
WAC, which is 1, because all
of them are 1 except for wc,
plus the rate constant which
is 1, times the input coming
in here, but
remember that was 0,
so actually it's just going
to be the same as the old WAC.
This is a metrical problem
between b and a, at the moment,
this is going to be the same.
All right.
Somethings are going
to change though.
What about wc, that was the
one that was actually not 1?
OK.
So new wc, remember,
the i for wc,
the i that we use
in this equation
is always negative 1
because it's a threshold.
So we have the old wc, which
is negative 0.5, plus 1 times
negative 1 times delta
c, which is one half.
So we have negative 0.5 plus
negative 0.5 equals negative 1.
w 1 a, well we've got
w 1 a starts out as 1.
Then we also know
that w 1 a is going
to be equal to 1 plus 1
times the input, which
is 1, times delta of a,
which is one half, so 1.5.
And since it's symmetrical
between a and b, then w 2
b is also 1.5.
And then finally, wa and wb,
the offsets here, well they
start at 1 plus 1 times
negative 1 times 0.5.
So they're both, everyone?
STUDENT: One half.
PROFESSOR: One half.
That's right.
Because negative 1 is their i.
Negative 1 times one half plus
positive 1 is just one half.
That's one full step.
Maybe a mite easier than
you might be used to seeing,
but there's a full step.
And it asks what's going
to be the output after one
step of backpropagation?
We can take a look.
So we have 1 times the new wa,
which is 1.5, you've got 1.5,
then the new wa is
just 0.5, now is
0.5, that's a 1
coming into an adder.
We've got another 1 coming in
here because it's symmetrical.
So 1 and a 1, 1 times WAC is 1.
1 times WBC is 1.
So we have two 1s coming in
here, they're added, that's 2.
Then this has become negative
1, in fact, at this point.
So negative 1 times negative 1,
that's 3, and the output is 3.
All right.
Cool.
We've now finished part b, which
is over half of everything.
Oh no, we've not.
One more thing.
These are adders.
They're not sigmoids.
What if we train this
entire neural net
to try to learn this
data, so that it
can draw a line on a
graph, or draw some lines,
or do some kind of learning,
to separate off the minuses
from all the pluses.
You've seen, maybe,
and if not, you
are about to in a
second, because it
asks you to do this in detail,
than neural nets can usually
draw one line on the
graph for each of these,
sort of, nodes in the net,
because each of the nodes
has some kind of threshold.
And you can do some logic
between them like ands or ors.
What do you guys think
this net is going to draw?
Anyone could volunteer,
I'm not going to ask anyone
to give this answer.
That's a little bit
tricky, because usually
if you had this many
nodes, you could easily
draw a box and box off the
minuses from the pluses.
However, it draws this.
And it asks what is the error?
The error is-- oh yeah, it even
tells you the error is 1/8,
because why?
These are all adders.
You can't actually
do anything logical.
This entire net boils
down to just one node,
because it just
adds up every time.
It never takes a
threshold at any point.
So you can't turn into
logical ones and zeroes,
because it's basically not
digital at all, its analog.
It's giving us some
very high number.
So it all boils
down to one cut off.
And that's the best one.
The one that I drew right here.
OK.
Did that not make sense to you?
That's OK.
This problem is much harder.
And putting them both on the
same quiz, was a bit brutal,
but by the time
you're done with this,
you'll understand what a
neural net can do or not.
I put these in simplified
form because of the fact
that we don't care about their
values or anything like that.
But inside of these little
circles is a sigmoid,
the multipliers and the
summers are implied.
I think in the simplified
form when we're not actually
doing backpropagation is
easier to view it, and see
how many nodes there are.
For the same reason
you asked your question
about how many there are.
So all of those big
circles are node.
And in those nodes is a sigmoid
now, not those crazy adders.
We have the following problem.
We have to try to
match each of a,
b, c, d, e, f to 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, using each of them
only once.
That's important, because some
of the more powerful networks
in here can do a lot of these.
So it's like yes, the
powerful networks could
do some of the
easier problems here,
but we want to match each
net to a problem it can do,
and there is exactly one
mapping that will map-- that
is one to one, and maps exactly,
uses all six of the nets
to solve all six of
these problems here.
So some of you may
be going like, what?
How am I going to
solve these problems?
I gave away a hint
before, which is
that each node in the neural
net, each sigmoid node
can usually draw
one line on the-- it
can draw one line
into the picture.
The line can be
diagonal if that nodes
receives both of the inputs,
which is here, i 1 and i 2.
See there is an i
1 and an i 2 axis.
Like x- and a y-axis.
The node has to be horizontal,
or vertical, if-- sorry,
the line has to be horizontal
or vertical if the node only
receives one of the inputs.
And then, if you
have a deeper level,
these secondary level nodes
can sort of do a logical,
can do some kind of brilliant
thing like and or or of
the first two, which
can help you out.
All right.
And so let's try
to figure it out.
So right off the bat, and I hope
that people will help and call
this out, because
I know we don't
have enough time that I can
force you guys to all get it.
But right off the bat,
which one of these
looks like it's the easiest one?
STUDENT: Six.
PROFESSOR: Six.
That's great.
Six is definitely
the easiest one.
It's a single line.
So this is just how I would
have solved this problem,
is find the easiest one.
Which of these is
the crappiest net?
STUDENT: A.
PROFESSOR: A is
the crappiest net.
But there's no
way in hell that A
is going to be able to get
any of these except for six.
So let's, right off the bat,
say that six is A. All right.
Six is A. That's A. We don't
have to worry about A. OK.
Cool.
Now let's look at some other
ones that are very interesting.
All the rest of
these draw two lines,
well these three draw two lines.
These three draw three lines.
They draw a triangle.
So despite the fact that this
c is a very powerful node,
that indeed, with three whole
levels here of sigmoids,
it looks like there's
only two that's
in our little stable of
nets that are equipped
to handle number one and two.
And those are?
E and F, because E and F have
three nodes at the first level.
They can draw three lines.
And then they can do something
logical about those lines,
like for instance, maybe, if
it's inside all of those lines.
There's a way to do that.
You just-- basically you can
give negative and positive
weights as you so
choose to make sure
that it's under certain
ones, above other ones,
and then make the threshold such
that it has to follow all three
of your rules.
So between E and F,
which one should be two
and which one should be one.
Anyone see?
Well let's look at two and one.
Which one is easier to do?
Between two and one.
Two.
It's got a horizontal
and a vertical.
One has all three diagonal.
And which one of these is a
weaker net, between E and F.
F. F has one node that
can only do a horizontal,
and one node that can
only do a vertical line.
So which one is F
going to have to do?
Two.
And E does what?
Good job, guys.
Good job, you got this.
So now let's look
at the last three.
Number three is
definitely the hardest.
It's an exceller.
Those of you who've
played around
with double o 2 kind of
stuff, or even just logic,
probably know that
there is no way
to make a sort of simple
linear combination in one
level of logic to
create an x or.
x or is very
difficult to create.
There are some
interesting problems
involving trying to teach
an exceller to a neural net.
Because a neural
net is not to be
able to get the x or, because of
the fact that you can tell it,
OK, I want this one to be
high, and this one to be low.
That's fine.
You say these both
have to be high.
That's fine.
It's hard to say, it's pretty
much impossible to say,
this one or this one, but
not the other, because need
to be high in a single node,
because of the fact that if you
just play with it, you'll see.
You need to set a
threshold somewhere,
and it's not going to
be able to distinguish
between, if the threshold
is set such that the
or is going to work, the
whole or is going to work.
It's going to accept when both
of them are positive as well.
So how we can do x or?
We need more logic.
We need to use some
combinations of ands and ors
in a two level way.
To do that we need the deepest
neural net that we have.
There's only one
that's capable of that.
And that is?
It's C.
There are many
different ways to do it.
Let's think of a possibility.
i 1 and i 2 draw
these two lines.
Let's call these one,
two, three, four, five,
node 1 and node 2
draw these two lines.
And I'll just sort of
draw it here for you guys.
Then maybe node 3
gives value to-- yeah,
let me see-- node three can
give value to perhaps-- let's
see-- node 3 can give value to
everything that is-- there are
a lot of possibilities here.
Node 3 can give value to
everything that is up here.
Actually node 3 can
give value to everything
except for this
bottom part, and then
node 4 could give value to
say-- doesn't do it yet,
but there's a few-- there's
a few different ways
to do it if you played around.
The key idea is that
node 3 and node 4
can give value to some
combination and or or not,
and then node 5 can give value
based on being above or below
a certain threshold,
combination of 3 and 4.
You can build an exceller
out of the logic gates.
I will ponder on that in the
back burner for a moment,
as we continue
onward, but clearly C
has to do number three.
OK.
Now we're left
with four and five.
I think, interestingly,
five looks
like it may be more complicated
than four, because of the fact
that it needs to do both
different directions instead
of two of the same direction.
So however, just the idea of
the one with the fewer lines,
being a simpler one, may
not get us through here.
And there's a reason why.
Look what we have left to use.
We have to use D or B. What is
the property of the two lines
that D can draw?
D being the simpler one.
One horizontal, one
vertical, that's right.
So even though it
may look simpler
to just have two
horizontal lines,
it actually requires B.
B is the only one that
can draw two horizontal lines
because D has to draw one
horizontal and one vertical.
So that leaves us with,
B on this, D on this.
Excellent, we have a question.
I would've thought it
would have been possible
that we had no
questions, or maybe
I just explained it
the best I ever have.
Question.
STUDENT: I didn't get why B
has to be two horizontal lines.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So the question is, I
don't understand why
B to be two horizontal lines.
The answer is, it doesn't.
B can be anything, but D
can't be two horizontal lines.
And so by process
of elimination,
it's B. Well take
a look at D, right.
So D has three nodes,
one, two, three.
Node 1 and node 2 can
just draw a line anywhere
they want, involving
the inputs they receive.
What input does node 1 receive?
Let's go to node 1.
So it can only make a
cut off based on i 1.
So therefore, it can only
draw by making the cut off
above and below a certain point.
Node 1 can only
draw vertical lines.
Node 2 can only draw
a horizontal line,
because it can
only make a cut off
based on where it is an i 2.
Therefore they can't
both draw a horizontal.
That's why this is
the trickiest part.
This last part, because
B is more powerful.
B does not only have to
do two horizontal lines.
It can do two diagonal lines.
It can do anything it wants.
It just happens that it's stuck
doing this somewhat easier
problem, because the fact that
it is the only one left that
has the power to do it.
So let's see, we're
done, and we'd
have aced this part of the
quiz that like no one got,
well not no one, but
very few people got,
when we put it on in 2008.
The only thing we
have left to ask
is-- let me see-- yeah, the
only thing we have left to ask
is what are we going
to do here for this?
All right.
Let's see.
For the x or, let's see
if I can do this x or.
OK.
How about this one.
Right.
I'm an idiot.
This is the easiest way.
Number one draws this line.
Number two draws this line.
Number three ends the
line, the two lines.
Number three says
only if both of them
are true, will I accept.
Number four maps the two lines.
And number five ors
between three and four.
Thank you.
No, it's not that hard.
I just completely
blanked, because there's
another way that a lot
of people like to do it.
It involves drawing
in a lot of lines,
and then making the clef b 2.
But I can't remember
it at the moment.
Or there any other questions?
Because I think if you
have a question now,
like four other people
have it and just
aren't raising their hand.
So ask any questions
about this drawing thing.
Question?
STUDENT: Why do we do this?
PROFESSOR: Why do we
do this drawing thing?
That's a very good question.
The answer is so that you
can see what kinds of nets
you might need to use in
these simple problems,
to answer these simple problems.
So that if Athena
forbid that you
have to use a
neural net in a job
somewhere to do some
actual learning,
and you see some sort of
quality about the problem,
you know not to make a
net that's too simple,
for instance.
And you wouldn't
want a net that is
more complex than it has to be.
So you can sort of see what
the net's do at each level,
and more visibly understand.
I think a lot of people who
drew problems like this just
want to make sure
people know, oh yeah,
it's not just these numbers
that we're mindlessly
backpropagating from the
other part of the problem
to make them higher or lower.
This is what we're
doing at each level.
This is the space
that we're looking at.
Each node is performing
logic on the steps before.
So that if you actually have to
use a neural net later on, down
the road, then you'll
be able to figure out
what your net's going
to need to look like.
You'll be able to figure
out what it's doing.
At least as well as
you can figure out
what it's doing,
for a neural net,
since it often will
start getting up
these really crazy numbers, will
have all sorts of nodes in it,
and like a real neural net
that's being used nowadays,
there'll be tons of
nodes, and you'll just
see the numbers
fluctuate wildly,
and then suddenly it's going
to start working or not.
That's a good question.
Any other questions?
We still have a few minutes.
Not many, but a few.
Any other questions
about any of this stuff?
Sorry.
STUDENT: Talk about
what you just asked.
Just because we draw it, does
the machine need to learn--
PROFESSOR: You're confused
why the machine is run what,
by the pictures on the right?
Oh OK.
Machine does not have to learn
by drawing pictures and calling
them in.
Let me give you some
real applications.
My friend at the
University of Maryland
recently actually
used neural nets
because, yeah, he actually did,
because of the fact that he
was doing an game plan
competition, where
the game was not known when
you were designing your AI.
It had to be able to-- there was
some very elegant, general game
solver thing that you had
be able to hook up into,
and then they made up the
rules, and you had a little bit
of time, and then it started.
Some of the AI's, what
they did was, they trained,
once they found out what
the rules were on their own,
with the rules, in his case he
had a neural net, because it
was so generic, you just
have a web of random gook.
He thought it could
learn anything,
and then-- he never did tell
me how it went, probably
didn't go well.
But maybe it did.
It basically tried to learn
some things about the rules.
Some of the other
people who are more
principled game players
actually tried to find out
fundamental properties
of the space of the rules
by testing a few
different things,
so they could view
more knowledge
is less search so they
could do less search
when the actual game
playing came on.
And then when the actual
game playing came on,
pretty much everyone did some
kind of game tree based stuff.
He's telling me that
a lot of Monte Carlo
based game tree stuff that is
this very non deterministic
as what they're doing
nowadays, rather than
what determines the
alpha beta, although he
said it converges to alpha beta,
if you've given enough time.
That's what he told
me, But that someone I
know who is using neural nets.
I've also in a cognitive
science class I took,
saw neural nets that tried
to attach like qualities
to objects, by having just
this huge, huge number of nodes
in levels in between, and
then eventually it was like,
a duck flies, and you're like,
how's it doing this again?
I'm not sure, but it is.
So the basic idea
is that when-- one
of the main reasons that
neural nets were used so much
back in the day is that
people on many different sides
of this problem,
cognitive science, AI,
whatever, were all
saying, wait a minute,
there's networks of neurons,
and they can do stuff,
and we're seeing it
in different places.
And when you've seen it in so
many different places at once,
must be a genius
idea that's going
to revolutionize everything.
And so then everyone
started using
them to try to connect all these
things together, which I think
is a noble endeavor,
but unfortunately people
just stopped using it.
It didn't work as they wanted.
It turned out that figuring out
our neurons worked in our head
was not the way to solve all
AI hard problems at once.
And they fall into
disfavor, although are still
used for some reasons,
like the sum is like that.
So we wouldn't use it just
to draw these pictures.
The reason why we
have these pictures
is because we give you simple
nets that you can work it out
by hand on the quiz.
Any net that is
really used nowadays
would make your
head explode, if we
tried to make you do
something with it on the quiz.
It would just be horrible.
So I think that's
a good question.
If there's no other questions,
or even if they are,
because we have to head out,
if there's any other questions,
you can see me as
I'm walking out.